Metoda de diagonalizare cuantică bazată pe eșantionare, sau SQD pe scurt, este un algoritm hibrid cuantic-clasic, la fel ca Kryov
diagonalizarea cuantică KQD, precum VQE și mulți alții. Când folosești astfel de algoritmi hibrizi,
poate fi util să te gândești la unde fiecare algoritm valorifică calculul cuantic și cel clasic. Reamintește-ți că VQE creează stări pe un quantum
circuit folosind parametri optimizați clasic. În acel caz, starea în sine se află pe un calculator cuantic. Deși
obținerea stării țintă este un proces care combină atât calculul clasic, cât și cel cuantic.
Valoarea de așteptare a operatorului este calculată folosind măsurători cuantice.
Dar este necesară și o combinare clasică a termenilor.
Spre deosebire, SQD folosește un calculator cuantic pentru a genera un subspatiu util pe care Hamiltonianul sau alt operator poate fi
proiectat. Hamiltonianul este apoi diagonalizat complet clasic pentru a găsi starea țintă. Să presupunem că avem o
problemă de interes pentru știință sau industrie care poate fi formulată ca o problemă de solver de valori proprii pe o matrice de n linii și
n coloane. Să presupunem în continuare că n este suficient de mare încât diagonalizarea clasică exactă nu este o opțiune. Ar fi
în mod clar avantajos să reduci dimensiunile matricei noastre, păstrând toate caracteristicile relevante ale stării fundamentale. Într-adevăr, acesta este
scopul multor abordări aproximative de solver de valori proprii, inclusiv metodele clasice kryoff. Să presupunem că știm suficient despre problema noastră pentru a face o
estimare rezonabil de bună despre forma stării fundamentale, dar nu suficient pentru a rezolva problema direct. În acel
caz, am putea face multe măsurători ale aproximării noastre a stării fundamentale țintă. Rezultatele acestor
măsurători ne oferă un subspatiu de stări de bază computaționale care conțin toate componentele relevante ale stării noastre
fundamentale. Proiectarea pe acel subspatiu ar produce o matrice mai mică care conține în continuare gradele relevante
de libertate. Fluxul de lucru pentru aceasta este următorul. Începi prin a alege un
ansatz bun. Mai precis, alege un ansatz al cărui suport coincide cu cel al stării țintă. Vom discuta exact ce
înseamnă asta. Apoi, măsoară starea în baza computațională, așa cum se face cu primitiva sampler.
Apoi, folosește rezultatele eșantionării pentru a defini un subspatiu care conține starea fundamentală.
Apoi, proiectează matricea ta pe acel subspatiu. În final, diagonalizează clasic matricea proiectată mai mică.
Să analizăm fiecare dintre acești pași, acordând o atenție deosebită definirii subspatiului.
În întregul domeniu al calculului cuantic, alegerea unui ansatz bun este întotdeauna critică. În cazul SQD, alegerea ta a ansatz-ului
va determina ce stări de bază computaționale pot fi măsurate în eșantionare.
Starea fundamentală adevărată poate fi exprimată ca o superpozitie a unui subset de stări de bază computaționale. Acel subset
se numește suportul stării fundamentale. Pentru a obține o estimare bună a stării fundamentale și a energiei sale, ansatz-ul tău
trebuie să aibă o proiecție nenulă pe stările de bază computaționale din suportul stării fundamentale.
Această diagramă reprezintă spațiul generat de toate stările posibile pe numărul de qubiți utilizați. Vrem un
ansatz al cărui suport conține suportul stării fundamentale adevărate.
Să considerăm un exemplu de sistem foarte mic cu o stare fundamentală s ground = 8 *
starea 1 0 0 plus 6 * starea 0 0 1.
Aceasta are un suport format din acei doi vectori 1 0 0 și 0 0 1. Să spunem că ansatz-ul are forma ANSATZ 1 este A ori
starea 1 0 0 plus B * starea 0 1 0 plus C * starea 0 0 1. Astfel încât
suportul său este mulțimea celor trei vectori 1 0 0, 0 1 0 și 0 0 1, o supramulțime a
suportului stării fundamentale. Acesta este un ansatz bun.
Acum imaginează-ți că am fi ales în schimb un ansatz de forma ANSATZ 2 este a * starea
1 1 0 plus b * starea 0 1 1.
Acesta are un suport format din acei doi vectori 1 1 0 și 0 1 1, care nu are nicio suprapunere cu suportul stării
fundamentale. Acesta este un ansatz prost.
Rețineți că nu este neapărat necesar ca ansatz-ul să fie o bună aproximare a stării fundamentale. Ansatz-ul ar putea
avea un suport mult mai mare sau coeficienții ar putea fi foarte diferiți pe ansatz și pe starea fundamentală adevărată și totuși să funcționeze bine.
În această etapă, am folosit un ansatz bine motivat pentru a face calculatorul cuantic să adopte o stare similară cu starea noastră țintă.
Prezentat aici este ansatz-ul unitar cuplate cluster sau UCJ, care este foarte util în chimia cuantică.
Acum vrem să măsurăm starea sistemului, obținând șiruri de biți care descriu starea colapsată a fiecărui
qubit. Reamintește-ți că estimarea Hamiltonianului, ca în VQE, necesită multe măsurători cuantice. Aceasta se datorează parțial
reducerii incertitudinii și parțial numărului de grupuri de operatori Pauli comutativi care alcătuiesc Hamiltonianul.
În metodele de eșantionare, ai în continuare nevoie de multe măsurători, dar motivele sunt diferite. Acum avem nevoie de multe măsurători pentru a eșantiona eficient
multele stări de bază computaționale implicate în stările cuantice înalt întricate. În SQD, șirurile de biți eșantionate corespund
configurațiilor sistemului simulat. Dacă sistemul studiat este supus unor constrângeri absolute, cum ar fi
legile de conservare în fizică sau chimie, atunci majoritatea stărilor măsurate vor fi valide. Dar unele șiruri de biți eșantionate
corespund unor configurații invalide sau nefizice din cauza zgomotului și erorilor. Un proces numit
recuperarea configurației urmărește să rafineze aceste eșantioane zgomotoase într-un set de configurații mai precise.
Acest proces implică generarea de noi configurații prin răsturnarea probabilistică a biților individuali, bazată pe
ocupanțele orbitale medii și numerele de particule cunoscute.
Configurațiile rafinate sunt apoi folosite pentru a genera subspatii pentru proiecția și diagonalizarea Hamiltonianului,
îmbunătățind iterativ fidelitatea reprezentării stării cuantice.
Să analizăm un exemplu trivial mic de recuperare a configurației pentru a înțelege semnificația sa. Să presupunem că măsurăm un
sistem cuantic cu patru qubiți reprezentând patru orbitale moleculare și obținem următoarele șiruri de biți de la
procesorul cuantic. Fiecare șir de biți reprezintă ocupanța unui orbital. Unu pentru
ocupat, zero pentru neocupat. Qiskit folosește o notație în care qubit-ul cel mai puțin semnificativ este în dreapta.
WEBVTT
De exemplu, 1 0 1 0 indică faptul că orbitalele 1 și trei sunt ocupate. Aceste
măsurători au fost alese doar din motive pedagogice. Ocupanțele rezultate pot să nu corespundă unui sistem fizic. În contextele fizice, este
adesea cazul că sistemul are un număr total cunoscut de particule. Pot exista și alte legi de conservare pe care
le poți folosi pentru a determina fizicalitatea unei stări măsurate. Ca să rămânem concreți, să presupunem că sistemul nostru este
cunoscut că are un număr total de particule n= 2. Aceasta ne spune numărul total de unu-uri care ar trebui să apară în eticheta stării noastre,
ceea ce se numește o constrângere de greutate Hamming.
Cu toate acestea, unele configurații măsurate încalcă această constrângere. Starea 1 0 1 0 este fizic validă. Dar starea 1 1
1 0 are prea multe particule, iar starea de toți zeroii are prea puține particule. Zero
de fapt. Aceste încălcări pot fi cauzate de zgomot în sistem sau erori de măsurare. Avem nevoie de o modalitate de a reveni
la configurații care au sens fizic, cel puțin în mod aproximativ.
Aceasta se numește recuperarea configurației.
Pentru a corecta eșantioanele noastre zgomotoase, răsturnăm probabilistic biții în configurațiile invalide, bazându-ne pe ocupanța orbitală medie
calculată ca medie peste configurațiile valide.
Ocupanțele orbitale sunt valorile de așteptare ale operatorului de număr acționând pe fiecare orbital. Aceasta este estimată și
rafinată auto-consistent folosind stările produse din SQD. Să ne uităm de exemplu la orbitalul 2. În două din cele
patru configurații valide, orbitalul 2 era ocupat. Aceasta ne dă o ocupanță așteptată de 0,5.
Facem același lucru pentru celelalte trei orbitale. Acum revenim la o configurație invalidă 1 1 0. Putem răsturna unul dintre
biți de la 1 la zero pentru a genera o configurație validă. Dar pe care ar trebui să îl răsturnăm? O modalitate de a decide este
prin deviația ocupanței fiecărui orbital față de mediile pe care tocmai le-am calculat.
Vedem că cea mai mare diferență este în ocuparea orbitalului unu. Deci ne-am putea aștepta că bitul unu ar trebui
răsturnat de la unu la zero. Desigur, orbitalul 2 nu este departe. Și este întotdeauna posibil, oricât de puțin probabil, că
această stare măsurată este rezultatul mai multor erori pe aceeași stare.
Alegerea doar a celei mai mari devieri față de medie pentru toate stările invalide nu este optimă. În schimb, biții sunt răsturnați
probabilistic, probabilitatea fiind o funcție a diferențelor prezentate aici. Să presupunem că în acest
caz schimbăm bitul care diferă cel mai mult față de ocupanța medie. Deci 1 1 0 devine 1 0 0. Am face același
proces pentru cealaltă alegere invalidă. Să spunem că în acest caz ajungem să răsturnăm biții unu și trei.
După acest proces de corecție, avem un nou set de configurații care ar putea arăta astfel.
Folosind acest set rafinat, putem actualiza ocupanța orbitală medie pentru a îmbunătăți fidelitatea. În cazul nostru, noile
ocupanțe sunt acestea.
Acest proces iterativ de recuperare asigură că măsurătorile zgomotoase sunt filtrate în configurații fizic semnificative,
îmbunătățind precizia aproximărilor stărilor proprii în SQD. Add-on-ul Qiskit pentru SQD are unele instrumente care
vor fi esențiale în acest proces. Dacă am eșantionat bine stările din suportul stării fundamentale adevărate
a sistemului, atunci ar trebui să putem privi doar acele părți ale Hamiltonianului care acționează pe acest subspatiu
și totuși să obținem o stare fundamentală și o energie bune. În exemplul nostru trivial mic de 4 qubiți, inițial există 2 la puterea 4, adică 16
stări posibile ale sistemului. Folosind o combinație de eșantionare și recuperare a configurației, reducem aceasta
la trei stări în subspatiul nostru de interes, trei stări despre care sperăm că alcătuiesc suportul stării fundamentale adevărate.
Acum proiectăm Hamiltonianul nostru complet pe acel subspatiu. Adică facem o matrice M dintr-o coloană de vectori din
subspatiul eșantionat recuperat și una analogă M conjugat transpus din linii și înmulțim M conjugat transpus H M
pictorial. Aceasta înseamnă luarea elementelor de matrice din liniile și coloanele corespunzătoare stărilor din
subspatiul eșantionat recuperat. Liniile și coloanele evidențiate sunt cele corespunzătoare subspatiului nostru. Și
casetele mai închis evidențiate unde se suprapun sunt elementele pe care le păstrăm pentru noua noastră matrice proiectată.
Acum că am selectat subspatiul de interes, putem diagonaliza această matrice pe un calculator clasic
folosind un solver standard. Dacă starea fundamentală adevărată este compusă în întregime din stări din subspatiul nostru, această
diagonalizare ar trebui să producă starea fundamentală corectă și energia stării fundamentale. Dacă avem doar cea mai mare parte a suportului stării fundamentale,
am putea obține un rezultat apropiat. Odată ce am obținut starea fundamentală pentru acest Hamiltonian proiectat, avem o stare
foarte utilă din care să calculăm ocupanța medie a fiecărui orbital.
Anterior, ocupanțele noastre au fost calculate din stările pe care le-am eșantionat folosind un ansatz despre care speram că ne va ajuta
să ne apropiem de starea fundamentală. Dar nu exista nicio garanție că ocupanța medie a fiecărui orbital din acea eșantionare corespundea ocupanței
din starea de energie minimă. Să facem un pas înapoi. Aveam o eșantionare de stări computaționale. Am folosit recuperarea configurației
pentru a corecta pe cele care erau fizic invalide. Apoi am calculat ocupanța orbitală medie folosindu-le pe toate. Este posibil ca
starea fundamentală să includă doar unele dintre ele. Starea fundamentală a acestui Hamiltonian proiectat poate să nu fie starea fundamentală adevărată
a sistemului nostru original, dar este starea de energie minimă care poate fi creată folosind orice superpozitie a
stărilor recuperate din subspatiul nostru. Ocupanța orbitală a acestei stări va produce o energie mai mică sau egală cu
energia ocupanței obținute din spațiul recuperat. Deci această ocupanță este o estimare mai bună a ocupanței
stării noastre fundamentale. Putem repeta procesul de recuperare a configurației folosind această nouă ocupanță și putem itera
până când criteriile noastre de convergență sunt îndeplinite. Diagonalizarea cuantică bazată pe eșantionare este rapidă comparativ cu
alți algoritmi pentru termen scurt precum VQE. Este mai scalabilă și este robustă la zgomot și erori în eșantionare. Necesită
totuși să pregătim un ansatz bun cu o proiecție mare pe suportul stării fundamentale adevărate a sistemului nostru. Dacă nu se știe nimic
despre starea noastră fundamentală adevărată, SQD poate trebui să fie folosit în combinație cu alte metode pentru a afla mai întâi despre
starea fundamentală și a se apropia iterativ de ea.
SQD joacă un rol critic în suita emergentă de algoritmi hibrid cuantic-clasici și este unul dintre
cei mai importanți factori care conduc spre calculul cuantic util.